JOHN: Good morning, Hank.
HANK: Good morning, John.
JOHN: It is Wednesday, I'm not really in the mood to make a proper video
*laughing* It's my Uncle Mike - He's bringing us flowers. Aw, thanks Uncle Mike. HANK: That's very sweet.
JOHN: Uh, however, we are going to play a game of Word Association today,
and then you're going to continue the game in comments. I'm going to start now. Lemon!
HANK: Pie!
JOHN: Meringue
HANK: Mushroom
JOHN: *laughing* Pizza!
HANK: Corndog
JOHN: Uh, hot dogs!
HANK: Doxen!
JOHN: Uh, poop-in-the-nintendo!
HANK: *laughing* Sonic the Hedgehog
JOHN: Uh - Mario
HANK: Um - Luigi
JOHN: Princess
HANK: Katherine!
JOHN: Awwww. Sweet!
HANK: Uh - Peppermint
JOHN: Um - uh - Minty.
HANK: Um, Mitt Romney.
JOHN: *laughing loudly*
Ummm - politician!
HANK: George Bush. JOHN: Rich people.
HANK: *laughing* Mountain Brook.
JOHN: *laughing loudly* HANK: That's where we are right now.
JOHN: Um... Country clubs.
HANK: Golf.
JOHN: Clubs.
HANK: Uh, Disco.
JOHN: *laughs* Balls.
HANK: Back to golf
JOHN: Back to golf! And disco! It's just beautiful - HANK: A loop.
JOHN: Just beautiful - BOTH: Disco golf balls. HANK: Disco golf ball loop. JOHN: Yes.
Somebody, right now, is making disco golf balls on Tumblr.
HANK: *stutters* They should be selling those on Etsy right now.
JOHN: Yeah - they will be. Don't worry. HANK: I'll buy one JOHN: DFTBA.com.
Now available for pre-order, BOTH: Disco golf balls! JOHN: Not really.
Not really, but you can get a Pizza John shirt.
HANK: Basket.
JOHN: Um, weaving.
HANK: Um... Underwater.
JOHN: *snicker* Swimming
HANK: Scuba.
JOHN: Um, acronyms that are -
HANK: That's a lot of - that's not a word. JOHN: Acronyms. HANK: There you go. Initialism.
JOHN: *chuckles* DFTBA.
HANK: Awesome.
JOHN: Um... Hank.
BOTH: Awwww. HANK: George Washington.
That's what Hank reminds me of! JOHN: *laughing* HANK: I remind myself of George Washington.
I don't know if you've ever noticed - I'm a really good General?
JOHN: Obelisks!
HANK: Ah. Uh, phallus.
JOHN: *stuttering* It's just - all balls and phalluses today, here. HANK: *laughing*
JOHN: Where am I supposed to go from "phallus?" What is that supposed to make me think of?
Um, Greek. Or possibly Latin. HANK: *laughing loudly* Soccer teams.
JOHN: *laughing* It is either Greek or Latin.
JOHN: I know from Crash Course! HANK: *laughing* JOHN: You will soon find out, my friend!
In episode 3 of Crash Course!
JOHN: Um, "soccer teams" makes me think of Hemlock.
HANK: Uh, makes me think of pine.
JOHN: Makes me think of sap.
HANK: Turpentine.
JOHN: Uh, makes me think of - that Turpentine-y smell. HANK: That is not a word. JOHN: That's a word!
HANK: It's a smell. JOHN: That-turpentine-y-smell.
HANK: Marble.
JOHN: Um... Venice.
HANK: Italy?
JOHN: Mmmm, corruption
HANK: Berlusconi.
BOTH: *laughing*
JOHN: Sex with 17-year-old girls. HANK: *laughing loudly* That's also not a word!
BOTH: *laughing* JOHN: Also not a word! Not a word.
JOHN: Did you ever see that headline of The Economist with Silvio Berlusconi,
and it just said - the headline on the cover was "The Man Who Screwed an Entire Country"? HANK: *laughing*
JOHN: So, uh, we're gonna stop there, and you're going to start at "Silvio Berlusconi."
HANK: *gasp* Oh, a dog! JOHN: Hey, Chief! It's a Doggie!
JOHN: So, the job now is that, in comments, you, the Nerdfighters, will continue our game of Word Association.
JOHN: Say hi to Chief. HANK: *imitating dog noises* Awrararar!
JOHN: Best wishes.